what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so as promised we are covering Avengers
extinction which is where cable wrecked
to the Avengers now here's the funny
thing this is actually the reason why
Avengers vs. x-men happened this is the
pre loot to the whole Avengers vs. x-men
thing which I didn't even realize it at
the time like when we do the Avengers
vs. x-men I don't even think about that
I was like man this is a prelude for
that and it actually makes the story
make a lot more sense so if you read
Avengers vs. x-men anywhere it's kind of
like okay this is weird this actually
really organizes it all if you never saw
Avengers vs. x-men you'll find my videos
for that down in the description but
nonetheless what this does is this
initially picks up with a group called
the lethal Legion
now the lethal Legion are totally
irrelevant they're like the non
spider-man version of the sinister six
right like the sinister six is like
spider-man's most notable rogues who
just kind of face off against him and
that's really it the lethal Legion is
one of a multitude of different groups
that exist out there to face off against
various superheroes for example back in
the 1960s the x-men had factor 3 you
have all these different you know
organizations and groups that face off
against traditional superheroes but what
happens in the middle of all this is
that when the Avengers initially pick up
facing off against the lethal Legion
suddenly Sam Wilson Falcon just vanishes
now this is kind of a crazy thing
because he's immediately incapacitated
and that's the end of him but right off
the bat we basically find out that the
person that's behind all this is
basically cable this is kind of cool
because what this does is this really
follows up to the events of the whole
like host House of M landscape in Marvel
Comics with the x-men going into like
Messiah Complex to Messiah War and you
know uncanny x-force and all those
different things now if you've read all
this stuff if you're familiar with the
x-men bear with me for a second because
there's a lot of people who are not the
idea here is that following house of
them when Scarlet Witch had basically
wiped out 98% of the mutant population
or at least took their powers away and
then just kind of you know left 198
mutants is the only one with any
abilities left
I wouldn't up happening is there was a
girl who was born in Alaska and nobody
knew what her name was because her
parents were killed when reverend
william stryker attacked alaska now if
william stryker is just this crazy guy
who believes that this is mission from
God to kill mutants and he leads a group
called the purifiers which are basically
people that share the same mindset as
him but the idea here is that William
Stryker had learned what was going
on the villain mr. sinister had learned
what was going on and sent his Marauders
and then the x-men picked up the birth
of host summers and they went to go
investigate as well the problem is that
once all three groups got there hope
Summers was nowhere to be found
now we ended up finding out that cable
had actually traveled to Alaska and
rescued her immediately released during
the events of William strikers assault
and then took her into the future the
problem with this was that the mutant
bishop who comes from a future very
similar to the Days of Future past but
we never learned what caused his future
it was basically revealed that this was
due to Hope Summers wiping out like a
million humans in six seconds it was
like the six-second war or something
along those lines and then Bishop
started chasing after cable in order to
try to get hooked that lasted all the
way from like Messiah Complex all the
way into Messiah 1 it's literally the
only thing that cable was doing he was
just taking hope into the future and
raising her as his daughter now of
course the reason she got the name Hope
Summers is because to use basically the
hope of mutant kind she's the mutant
Messiah and in the last name Sommers
because that's cables last name now the
other half of this is that it focuses on
the nature of cable himself now we don't
have to get too deep into this I'm
assuming that most of you guys who are
watching this video right now anyway
recently watched my cable video so if
all you really need to worry about if
you're not you know really familiar with
him is the cable is the the son of
Cyclops and he's basically
time-displaced he was thrown four
thousand years into the future and just
raised there so that's the only thing we
really need to focus on for getting you
know to understand this video but the
idea here in terms of why cable is back
is not initially given to us instead all
it really happens is Captain America
realizes that Sam Wilson's missing he
basically kind of follows the bird of
Sam Wilson Red Wing and then eventually
tracks Sam Wilson down to where cable as
keeping falcon held after which the two
of them basically engage in a conflict
now here's the funny thing this is
something to think about
cable is able to easily overpower
Captain America and that's the funny
thing about this because Captain America
is routinely demonstrated to us as one
of the most notable fighters in Marvel
Comics but the idea here is that cable
completely incapacitated Captain America
and this is when we learn why it is that
he's here what we end up doing is we
actually pick up with a character named
blacksmith the blacksmith was a guy who
was created by Jeff blow back in 1995
with x-men prime number one but
blacksmith is basically just an ally
Kable from his own timeline but what
blacksmith does is he tells cables that
after the events of Messiah War Messiah
Complex and all that kind of stuff what
Hope Summers had come back to the
present day
somewhere along the line an event is
going to take place this going to
basically lay waste to the future and
the reason why is because there will be
a point when Hope Summers will be needed
but she won't be there now the event
that lays waste to the future is not
what intrigues cable what intrigues
cable is that Hope Summers isn't there
and when the question is asked why
wasn't she there the answer given by
black Smith is well because she probably
died now that's what sets all this stuff
in motion because this is basically just
a story for cable travels back into the
past and says we have to find a way to
deal with hope now just by following the
Avengers vs. x-men storyline to its most
logical conclusion what we know is that
cable was basically told by by
blacksmith the events of Avengers vs.
x-men that Hope Summers would become the
Phoenix the avengers would fear the
return of the Dark Phoenix Jean Grey
more or less that hope would basically
become a bad guy and potentially lay
waste to the entire earth as though the
Avengers wanted to keep her in custody
the x-men wanted to keep her with them
which led to the two factions fighting
one another the indication here is that
in the future that cables from Hope
Summers did not survive she basically
died and the result was that cables
going back in time to keep that from
happening
but here's the funny thing about this is
because as cable begins to go through
the various you know resources and so on
kind of talking to Captain America one
of the things that's given to us here is
that the Avengers were preparing for a
war with the x-men what that war was
going to be we don't know all we know is
that somewhere along the line the
Avengers began to view the x-men as a
credible threat and the result was that
the Avengers began to stockpile arms and
armament against them now it's not as
though the Avengers were going to go out
and launch the first strike and we're
going to run out there and just say okay
so now we're ready for our war with the
x-men let's bomb the Xavier Institute
that's not exactly that's not what the
Avengers would do instead they would
wait for a time when the x-men would
strike and that would make sense I mean
even if it's not just the x-men per se
one thing to keep in mind here is that
with the events of house of M basically
unfolding and the mutant population
being reduced down to such a small
number cyclopses tactics began to grow
more and more extreme who is basically
trying to find a way to consolidate
all meetings of existence directly under
his authority not only that he was
looking at at preserving the mutants
anybody who came along and offered
themselves as a credible threat to
mutants was an enemy no questions asked
no if ands or buts that's just the way
it was that was the philosophy of the
x-men really under Cyclops and Emma
Frost during that time that's why all
this stuff eventually led everything
after the events of house of M was just
this massive story that eventually led
to Cyclops becoming a tried and true bad
guy and basically becoming magneto with
regards to this particular story the one
thing to keep in mind is that cables
from the future and so what he had done
alongside blacksmith which basically
stockpile all different kinds of
technology and so on and so forth the
two that Sam Wilson is currently stuck
in is actually the Weapon X tube is the
same tube that was used when Wolverine
was undergoing the adamantium bonding
process the chair that Captain America
is sitting that's the same chair that
magneto used back in the 1960's and
1970's when he basically began the
process of trying to incapacitate the
x-men he has Tony Stark's Iron Man armor
that hasn't been invented yet that's the
danger of facing off against cable when
you fight against cables you're not just
fighting against a telepath and a
telekinetic you're fighting the future
if you're someone like Iron Man you're
fighting technology that you haven't
made yet and that's a great big thing
about this is because remember cable is
as much a tactician as he is a guy who
knows how to use various forms of
technology at his disposal now of course
this battle between himself and iron man
leads directly into the water and the
funny thing about this is that cable is
basically fighting a conflict on two
fronts the first front is east fighting
against Iron Man the second is that he's
trying to keep this techno-organic virus
from eating him alive remember that's
the nature of cable cable whatever it is
that he has this techno-organic virus
basically converting his biological
cells in the machinery a time will come
when he will basically just be complete
and total machinery that'll be it and
it'll actually be in this story which is
really kind of cool but the funny thing
about this is that despite Tony Stark's
best efforts at the end of the day it
doesn't matter and the reason why is
because of the fact that cable knows
every single one of Iron Man's tactics
not only that because of the fact that
he's part machine he can hack into all
different kinds of machinery being that
he's so advanced Tony Stark has no way
of protecting himself against the
escapades of table meeting cable
basically into Iron Man
and essentially turns it against him
incapacitating him filling him in one of
the chairs now this leads into the
conflict of Red Hulk and this is cool
because Red Hulk is a foe that cable has
never faced off against cables faced off
against a version of the Red Hulk named
general Talbot but he's never faced off
against the actual Red Hulk general
Thunderbolt Ross and that's kind of the
cool thing here because they're two
distinctly different characters remember
we talked about all this when we did our
run on red tacks whole Incredible Hulk
with Red Hulk and all that kind of stuff
you'll find that massive playlist down
there but Red Hulk is a combination of
general Thunderbolt Ross as
battle-hardened experience and his
desire to defeat The Incredible Hulk
combined with all these powers that he
has the ability to just increase his
heat as he gets angrier his increased
strength is increased durability so on
and so forth and the result is that
cable facing off against Hulk it's not
as simple as just trying to beat the guy
or trying to use a telepathy or
telekinesis and in fact table is pretty
swiftly incapacitated but what this does
is it leads into blacksmiths who
basically jumps in on behalf of cable
now again this is kind of a cool moment
here and the reason for that is because
of the fact that for the most part Red
Hulk has cable on the run cables trying
to keep this virus from eating him alive
but it's slowly and surely basically
killing him off now the reason for this
is because of the fact that once all
this started you know in the beginning
back in the future when cable was being
told by blacksmith everything that was
going on
blacksmiths was basically like by the
way you only have like 24 hours until
the technical organic virus eats you
alive your telepathy is just not what it
used to be you're not going to be able
to keep this virus at bay any longer
it's going to basically kill you and
that makes sense and it's actually a
pretty intelligent way to do things
because it explains why it is that in
older stories like in the 1990s cable
was so much more powerful than he is
right now because if this story had been
written back in the 90s cable would have
made mincemeat out of these guys it
would have been child's play to take out
Red Hulk and Captain America and Sam
Wilson it would not have been any effort
whatsoever because he was just that
powerful but as he's progressed his
skill set his abilities they just begun
to decrease in terms of his ability to
use them effectively and the result is
that what he actually ends up doing in a
moment of panic is simply dispersing
these talents up against Red Hulk and
effectively infects him with a teknorg
an
virus once the techno-organic virus
begins infecting a person unless they're
like some super high-level Omega level
telepath like cable they're not going to
be able to keep it at bay they're not
going to be able to keep it off it's
going to absolutely ravage their body to
the point where it's basically going to
kill them and so what ends up happening
here is that in this moment when cable
is essentially getting ready to kill Red
Hulk we're suddenly met with the arrival
of Cyclops and Hope Summers and of
course this was done by way of
blacksmith just because of the fact that
it was one thing for cable to go back in
con and say I want to keep the Avengers
from doing whatever it is they're going
to do that's going to lead to the
incapacitation of pope summers or her
potential death and it's another to go
back in time and say I'm going to kill
the Avengers because their actions their
war against the x-men is going to result
in the death of hope it's a line the
blacksmith is not ready to cross and the
result is that he recruits the x-men in
order to defeat cable and that's kind of
a funny thing about this because this is
where things begin to pop off what we
end up finding out here is that we're
the beginning of the story saw the
Avengers fighting the lethal Legion the
reason for this is because of the fact
that all the members of the lethal
Legion were being taken to a prison but
cable shot down the prison transport in
order to serve as a distraction to begin
kidnapping the various members of the
Avengers now initially it was Wolverine
who picked this up it was Wolverine who
figured out what was going on and this
makes sense because remember Wolverines
been around for a long long time and
Wolverine has met and been allies and
fought against cable on a multitude of
occasions so when Wolverine you know
grata gathers the rest of the rest of
the Avengers and basically begins
bringing them in to face off against
cable Wolverine realizes it's no joke
when cable comes into the conflict when
cable comes to fight he plays for keeps
he does not play to take prisoners and
that's the coolest thing about this is
because Wolverine goes right off the bat
if it comes down to it Cable will kill
them all and he will not ask any
questions about it and so Wolverine
replies and kind by making the battle
just as lethal now what this does is
answer a question can Wolverine cut
through cables technological
enhancements or you know his arm is
italic arm and so on and so forth yes he
can easily cut through that what is it
happening here is it actually leads to
hope summers going through and freeing
everybody and in the process
Cable facing off against the Avengers
and the x-men at the same time now again
this is short-lived
it's a
very very small moments but remember
cable is a telepath an omega-level
telepath and omega-level telekinetic
meaning feeds of the highest order when
it comes to being a telepathic and
telekinetic the problem with this is
that again the techno-organic virus is
just ravaging his body and so it gets to
the point where he just simply can't
fight anymore and he effectively just
gives out but had that not been the case
he would absolutely wreck all of them I
mean he would destroy them all now what
is dead or at least the purpose of this
story is it allowed Marvell to basically
bring the character of cable back
without the whole issue of the teknorg
antivirus this story was in effect a
soft reboot for cable and the reason why
is because once everything is all said
and done Hope Summers effectively cures
him a bit techno-organic virus now
remember this is not a new ability for
Hope Summers it's one of the things that
was immediately introduced with her
character we all know that just because
of the fact or at least those of you who
have read it know that because of the
character of ro there was a story that
has taken place with rogues character
before the events of Messiah Complex I
think it was where the Shiar had this
thing called a hecka tomb
and it was basically this massive bomb
that was empowered or at least possessed
by the spirits of just countless people
who had died there came a point where
rogue had touched it and absorbed just
these countless mines into her head I
drove her absolutely bonkers and she
simply went into a catatonic state
following the events of Messiah Complex
mystique actually kidnaps Hope Summers
as an infant and it took Hoke summers
hand and touched it to rogue and cured
her of all these personalities
effectively resetting rogues powers back
to zero what also ends up happening here
is that which Hope Summers touching
cable under the belief that perhaps
cable maybe die or that he is gone what
is up happening is that in this moment
of you know emotional duress she
manifests as the Phoenix force and this
is huge because Cyclops is the one that
sees it happen now remember just because
a person manifests the Phoenix powers
does not mean they are the tried and
true Phoenix this is a way that Marvel
basically uses to say this person can
become the Phoenix that was the nature
of the Avengers vs. x-men story is that
eventually the Phoenix force itself
returned with the intention of bonding
itself to Hope Summers it's basically
this idea that hopes send out an SOS or
sort of a signal to the Phoenix
basically saying I'm ready for the power
that you possess and the Phoenix showed
up with the intention of giving her that
now what isn't happening here is that
with cable basically healing this story
basically comes to an end when cable
reaches out telepathically to Scott
Summers says look there's a war that's
coming the Phoenix force will return and
when it does it will try to bond itself
to Hope Summers when that threat is
initially detected by the Avengers the
Avengers will respond by trying to take
Hope Summers what cable says is I want
you to make me a promise from a father
to a son that if anything happens to
Hope Summers you will do everything in
your power to make sure that she stays
protected that she does not fall in the
hands of the Avengers that Hope Summers
is allowed to step into her destiny as
becoming the Phoenix and so again that's
why the entirety of the Avengers vs.
x-men event happened in truth because of
the fact that it was just Cyclops
keeping a promise to his son but without
being said guys I thought it was a
pretty cool story cable just wrecking
the entirety of the Avengers in the
x-men is one of the coolest things to
see it's one of my favorite moments when
it comes to its character but anyway
guys we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]